nice alright so what we have here is a
coffee cup on a loud speaker and we
drive in a loud speaker with a signal
generator here where we can vary the
frequency so the rate at which the
speaker goes up and down and the
amplitude which just means the volume
then that goes to a power amplifier
which is just an amplifier goes into the
speaker so it's a very simple setup it
allows us to connect something which
might seem very mundane like a cup of
coffee very special to me though a cup
of coffee with very what might appear to
be very used to tarrick physics this is
one of my if not my favorite image in
all of physics basically a Brady and I
have talked about this at length before
and various other videos but let me just
explain briefly what it is what we have
is a ring of iron atoms and those iron
atoms have been painstakingly placed
there using something called a scanning
tunneling microscope that's a remarkable
feat of atomic scale engineering but
that's not the good thing what those
atoms those iron atoms are sitting on is
a copper surface where the electrons of
the copper surface spread out like a sea
like a fluid like a liquid and what
you're seeing within what they call a
quantum Corral here is the wave-like
nature of those electrons you see in the
waves that those electrons make because
they scatter off the atoms just like
wave scattering off when they hit an
object in a lake or a portal or you drop
a stone in a portal you see the ripples
that's what you're seeing you're seeing
those are ripples of those electron
waves and what's remarkable and this
really truly is remarkable is that this
which is happening on a 10 nanometer
roughly 10 nanometer length scale it's a
tiny tiny
not beyond microscopic nanoscopic land
scale is that the pattern we see there
the mathematics of that pattern is
exactly the same as the pattern we see
in this coffee column and you would have
seen patterns like these if you're
sitting on a train and the trains
bouncing around and it's quite a nun
studying you've got your copper coffee
sitting in front of you and you look
down what you'll see are these
concentric rings you'll see this part
and what that is is a manifestation of
something called a Bessel function that
the mathematics that describes this
pattern is something called a Bessel
function and it comes from what it is is
a standing wave so just as we have let
me get the guitar abuti oh this is
actually this would work well because
this is one D and that's to D you're
very familiar with guitars and you're
very familiar with strings and the
sounds they make and the notes they make
and that's because what we have here is
a wave that's confined to that string
it's called a standing wave or
alternatively it's called a resonance of
the of the string so that's a
one-dimensional system it's a line it's
a string it's one-dimensional what we
have here is a two dimension and analog
a two-dimensional standing wave
so instead of it being along a line this
covers an area when the iron atoms are
placed on here filming the sort of
defense of the corral yeah what's then
causing the wave inside is something
coming out to the elect because the
electrons are travelling all the time
and so the electrons are scattering off
the the ring and then they're scattering
back so you've got a wave going in that
direction and a way of coming back and
that's exactly how a standing wave forms
except in this case it's in two
dimensions so it's a reflection wave
going that way wave coming back they
form a standing wave so that's what you
see there what what is it about the
corral of 50 atoms or so that caused
that wave
show itself whereas it doesn't show up
self outside brilliant question actually
it does show itself outside look
carefully you see these ripples you see
these rings and you see the rings around
this it does show itself when those
electron waves are traveling and they
scare if that was a perfectly defect
free surface it was nothing on that
surface there were no adsorbed free
atoms there was nothing else perfectly
flat then those electron waves wouldn't
scatter off anything you wouldn't see
these patterns what you see now is the
atom D let the the electron wave comes
along the atom is there and that atom
scatters the wave the wave reflects what
rocks in the sea exactly precisely like
rocks in the sea and you can see that in
all the waves rippling off from that is
exactly the same effect and okay I can
see so I can see a rock in the sea yeah
exactly what is it about the corral it's
the symmetry it's the key thing here is
the symmetry it's a circle and if you
have a square arrangement of atoms
different pattern if you for triangular
ends with different pattern hexagonal
arrangement they even did what are
called stadia which are semi circle and
then like a rectangular bed and then
another semicircle to look for patterns
in fact chaotic patterns in those but
the beauty of this is the circular
symmetry so what we have here is a
standing wave with our particular
symmetry and that's where this Bessel
function idea comes in and so what's
happening here is we've got this strip
this structure what we have here is
something which is on happening on earth
or real world then scale about 32
million million of these could fit on
the surface of this and this is what
blows physicists mind when the same mass
that describes this describes this
despite the fact you've got this huge
disparity in land scales that's when we
really get excited that's when we really
get fascinated by these things
what I'm trying to avoid here is we
reach a point where the amplitude the
magnitude of the wave is so big that the
fluid starts to slosh but I want to keep
the surface flat otherwise but I have
captured feel doing it wrong
yes you have captured me doing it wrong
very very many times and as a classic
paper actually in a American Physical
Society Journal from a couple of years
ago where they worked out the key
properties of slush and coffee and the
best strategy to adopt if you want to
walk with your cup of coffee along the
corridor and not unlike me spill it
everywhere so what I'll do is I'll play
around with the amplitude in the
frequency and you can see the different
patterns so I'll just build the
amplitude you can see the whole thing
shake and because it's it's something
called a resonance there would be a
certain frequency where we expect to see
a stronger response before the resonance
is and now what we can do is we can
bring the amplitude up and I'll show you
what happens if we get the amplitude too
high you start to see that sloshing
motion and you get another set of
patterns or now whap at thirty thirty
Hertz and now it's gone so we're still
vibrating but what thirty eight Hertz
circle and it's gone what can you see
them yes
oh really okay so the sloshing motion
seems to go now I can see it yeah cool
the electrons on the copper surface that
are inside the corral yep are they
basically moving along hitting a wall
coming back exactly that's exactly at a
tract yeah the trap that's exactly what
it is that's what a standing wave is a
trap with yeah they're trapped in the
career and they interfere we have to
either in this special that's exactly it
and a cop it's exactly the except did
these or are atoms the edge of the
corpus or or atoms this is our boundary
and what's the coffee and the coffee is
the same as the electron fluid here so
the coffee is playing the role of the
electron fluid